[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to the session I hope you
enjoyed the day so far
my name is yen's I'm a solution
architect at Google and I have with me
role from BT who's ahead of say a
specialist there and who will talk about
their company later and our partnership
today I'm going to talk about Google
cloud networking for enterprises now
when you think about enterprise in the
cloud there's a few things which are
always important and I'm going to touch
on quite a few of them and how
especially the networking part of
Google's cloud can help you with them
one of them is scaling your application
that's very important that's why I come
to the cloud in the first place once
it's how you keep all of that secure
then always when you talk to enterprises
you don't move everything at once so you
want to securely connect both the old
and new environment and then as a last
thing ever talk about virtual private
cloud which is the concept which came
over the last few years and how we are
simplifying it a little bit and after
that row will we'll talk about hybrid
infrastructure hybrid cloud
infrastructure which is also on top of
minds for every enterprise but let's
start with scale let's say you build an
application in the cloud a multi-tier
application there's a few things you
don't really care about the first is it
needs to be globally available
everywhere for users around the globe at
a low latency it needs to be reliable
always available you want to order scale
with your demands up and down and you
want to optimize it for cost as well and
then the best if it's portable so in
case you're not happy you can move to
another cloud or you can even even
on-premise and how we do that in Google
cloud platform is with some of those
products listed here because out load
balancing our CDN I will talk about now
our interconnect I will talk in the
extra part and then you need some kind
of Google cloud product to actually run
the application this can be anything can
be container engine with kubernetes to
be super portable but it can also be
just a virtual machine
menaced instance groups any of those
products let's start with global you
want to have users around the globe for
your application and that's where Google
cloud platform with the network can help
you because we have a global
infrastructure here you see green dots
these are the regions we currently offer
on our platform where you can run
virtual machines and we have blue dots
which are regions which we will open
over the course of 2017 and 2018 that
but what's really important is two gray
dots and and the blue lines because
that's our points of presence which
interconnected by our network and your
users will always enter the network at a
closed point closest point to their
location regardless where the data is
sitting and we have over a hundred of
them around the globe and over 80 of
them run what we call the Google front
end which is where load balancing
happens so when you want to load balance
your applications we have five flavors
of load balancing but today I want to
talk about global load balancing there
we have HTTP HTTP load balancing for for
HTTP workloads for other secure
workloads we have an SSL proxy and then
we have a TCP proxy for for for
unencrypted traffic um and all of those
use what I just call out the Google
front-end which we have in over 80
locations now let's look at the dates in
detail on the left you see a traditional
load balancer here and on the right you
see how this works on Google cloud
platform you don't really see a lot on
us at all you have these Google
front-end sitting at the edge of our
network around the globe and they all
sync with each other of a global control
plane and talk to each other and know
where there's available capacities to
serve your application so they can
direct your users to the closest
available data center now that means
that users in California can access the
service you have deployed in the US
users in London get routed automatically
to your VMs in Europe and users in Asia
get automatically routed to VM Steyr
what's different from other clouds as
well as we don't use DNS for full load
balancing this you get one single
P around the globe for all of this and
you can have this know an ipv4 and now
as well on ipv6 in beta now once you
have your application your load
balancing setup you might want to
optimize more for cost or even even more
for latency and caching and CDN makes
absolute sense for that in Google Cloud
we have two options for that you can use
Google Cloud CDN you can activate that
fit there's a single click it's
integrated with our load balancer or if
you already have an existing contract
with a CDN provider and need some
advanced features you can use any of our
partner CDN providers and we've give you
a discounted rate for egress to those
now you have the application running
it's load balanced it's caching but a
multi-tier application you need to talk
to services within your network with it
with each other and you don't want to
expose to us by a public IP so you have
the same load balancing scale you have
externally as well by an internal load
balancer to run this we use a technology
called um Andromeda now what is
Andromeda
it's our software-defined networking
infrastructure we built especially for
Google compute engine and that allows us
for faster startup times for high speed
and low latency and we can quickly
include and and augment our network
virtualization functions such as
firewall I'm talking about later or or
that internal load balancing we ran
through several iterations of the
Andromeda data plane in the last few
years are currently be rolling out
Andromeda - one which helps you bypass
the hypervisor so you can talk directly
to the network interface card on the
machine in the use of space and we want
to bypass that directly so you can talk
directly to the physical hardware from
your virtual machine in a few trait
duration now what does that mean for you
this makes it possible for us to
increase the speed you get between VMs
you can now get up to sixteen gigabit
per second it leads to lower latency but
one thing which is often overlooked is
it also leads to less CPU come
consumption on the host where we run the
VM and on your VM guest machine and that
means if you have Network and CPU
intensive applications they run much
more smoothly than before now this is
how we can help you scale the
application let's talk about security
because this is really on top of mind
for enterprises in a traditional
environment when you think about
security you think about routers
firewalls DDoS protections and a lot of
boxes like ids/ips web application
firewalls lots of this is virtualized in
the Google cloud so let's look at them
and how you can move those concepts over
to the Google cloud the first thing is
routing and switching in a traditional
environment traffic comes from the
internet moves through several layers
until it gets to top of rack switch and
in the end to your physical host in in
the Google cloud platform you have
machines talking to the each other but
the network infrastructure in between is
completely virtualized it's runs through
our Software Defined Networking so you
don't have to configure every say
anything there and you don't have to
care where the machines are physically
located at all but if you want to do
some advanced functionality advanced
routing for example you want to push
some traffic to a certain address range
through a gateway you can do that with
advanced routing range rules as well
virtualized we all have we put these
these things in place seamlessly through
our software-defined network in a
typical data center network firewalls
are often a choke point because firewall
capacity is not the same capacity as the
rest of the network now if you think
back on the previous slide there was no
firewall at all listed in the Google
cloud platform that's because it's
distributed and it's on every single
host we distribute the firewall and it's
enforced at a host level now in the past
you have we had firewalls on Google
cloud platform so you could you could
you could say which traffic can come
into a VM
but we recently added two new feature
one is you can also now control traffic
outgoing from VM egress firewalls and as
well you can set permit and deny rules
so you can you can have rules
overlapping each other and and set those
with a priority which which get then
looked at in sequence so you can do the
same kind of complex access control
lists you used from on-premise you can
now move those more or less one to one
to the Google cloud platform if you
think about distributed denial of
service attacks you will be happy to
hear that with if you either use Google
cloud load bouncer or Google cloud CDN
we haven't built in layer 3 layer 4 DDoS
defense already and our global high
speed and high-capacity network makes
sure that we can absorb attacks of any
kind of size and scale now if that's not
enough for you and if you want
additional protection you can use any of
our third-party DDoS protection partners
and put an additional layer of defense
in now you have when you have all this
in place you might still want some
specialized security appliance or you're
already tied very closely to a vendor
let's say for example you want to put a
Web Application Firewall in place or all
you used to running checkpoint firewall
and you want to use the same rules in
the cloud you use on-premise now I'm
happy to announce that most of the major
appliance vendors know of a virtualized
version of their appliances automatic at
which you can launch easily with a few
clicks in our Google cloud launcher
so to recap security is a layered
approach and this is the same way we see
it at the core you have a secure virtual
private cloud you have distributed
firewall you have Identity and Access
Management and a lot of other features
some of which I will touch on a little
bit later then on around this you have a
secure interconnection which I will now
go into you can have third-party virtual
appliances adding even extra features to
that and then you have our load bar
which has practically unlimited capacity
for you and has built-in layer 3
therefore DDoS protection around all
that we have our global Google Network
which can absorb any kind style and kind
of attack and then as an outer layer of
defense you can use this another third
party leaders defense mechanism on top
of that if you wish now we talked about
scale we talked about security but you
also want to know how you want to
interconnect your own existing
environment with the Google cloud and
I'm happy to tell you that this card a
lot easier we used we used to have only
these three mechanisms we have a direct
peering mechanism where you meet us in
one of our points of presence around the
globe you have a carrier and to connect
functionality where you use a partner
such as BT to provide the service for
you but all of this only provided a
public view into our products like over
public IP addresses and the only way you
had to connect privately to us was by a
VPN tunnels the advantage we have this
private interconnect service actually
gives you access to all Google services
so not only Google cloud platform but
also all three suite services like Docs
and sheets and mail but even our
consumer services as YouTube etc are
available over that link but for private
access you were limited to VPN we do
have a high availability option there so
you can have one or multiple tunnels so
you can have a secure and stable link
but what enterprises are looking for
usually in an easier way so I'm happy to
announce that we will soon be offering
Google cloud interconnect which provides
a private access of a private IP
addresses directly into your project
from your enterprise which enables an
easy hybrid cloud deployment and you
don't need a VPN anymore and we offer
this in two flavors private interconnect
apartment Connect now let's look at this
in detail
private interconnect means you made us
at one of our colocation facilities
around the globe and you put your
peering router there and you
interconnect with us and we drop you
directly into your project now partner
interconnect means you have a service
provider partner in between with which
which might be already in our facility
so the service provider can you meet you
where you are located like at your
enterprise headquarters or your existing
data center and it and depending on the
service you might not even need a router
in place but you just get an Ethernet
connection which drops you into your
project now we offer private
interconnect in at launch in all the
green locations around the globe so in
Europe that's London Amsterdam Frankfurt
but later this year we will expand this
further to more locations including
Madrid now once you have a private
interconnect like that you want to also
have this in a reliable way
unfortunately on a single circuit we
cannot offer you any type of SLA because
justify one might be Kartik someone
might trip over the cable this is not
possible but as soon as you have two
lengths in one location we can offer you
in 99.9 percent availability SLA on that
if you go globally and you have you have
several inter connections to us cross
sides we can offer you up to five nines
of availability for this now we talked
about scale we talked about security and
we talked about how you can interconnect
with our with our network now I want to
take a few minutes to talk and show you
how we evaluated concept of virtual
private cloud which came up in the
industry and how what we thought about
how we could make this a little bit
different now if you think about a
virtual private cloud there's a few
things which sets its apart one that is
global so you can have a single virtual
private cloud which spans across many
regions
even across the globe it's shareable and
I will go into detail and show you what
that means later it expandable that
means you don't have to set your network
addressing in stone you can easily
change it later and I will also demo
that and you can have a private access
to other Google services now let's go a
bit into detail into all of that now
when I talk about a global we perceive
we need to look at a traditional VPC
first traditionally virtual private
clouds are regional so once you expand
your Google your cloud usage to another
region you might have to set up an inter
connection between these regions either
over the internet over APN or via other
means it's not automatic now with Google
cloud this has always been automatic you
can easily access your machines your
virtual machines which are located in
another region around the globe you can
there is no extra this there's no extra
configuration required for that and the
traffic all flows securely through our
Google own backbone Network now the big
difference between our VPC and some
other virtual private cloud is also that
our VPC can be shared across an
organization now when you look at other
VP C's it's kind of for developers very
hard to use the cloud because they might
not be networking specialists they might
not know how to use the network they
actually coming from an on-premise
environment they never had to care about
the network so why do they suddenly have
to set up firewall rules or rotting
rules or interconnection VPNs etc now
luckily since in Google we offer shared
VPC or cross-project network you can
have one virtual network which spans
across your whole organization and where
you provide the network as a service to
your developers which might still be in
separate projects for administration and
billing purposes now let's let's look at
this in a detail you have an
organization where all your projects it
and in this organ
you create a project which will be the
shared VPC host network and that one has
a security in the network admin which
care for all the firewall rules the
routing rules and the secure
interconnection back back to your
premises then in this shared network you
can create subnets and you can share
those subnets across different projects
so you can add projects to this let's
say you have different groups working on
web service recommendations and
analytics and all of those need to talk
to each other but centrally it's decided
who creates those rules so for the for
the product member that's also an
advantage because they get a network as
a plug-and-play they need to get done
need to care about the network security
they don't need to care about a private
and secure interconnection now sometimes
you need to interconnect to other
networks in Google cloud which might not
be in your organization all you want to
do it the other way where actually the
project owner wants to set the
networking rules so for those people we
also offer a more traditional VPC
Network peering where one projects owner
says he wants to talk to project B
project B says he wants to talk to
project a and we put a secure
interconnect over a software-defined
network in place that that you can talk
to each other privately without going
through public IP addresses that's even
a third way and that is that you can
have now this multi NIC you can have one
VM have multiple network interface cards
and those can be in different networks
so this is for example used in many of
the virtual appliances I talked about
earlier last but not least I want to
talk about the private access to Google
services now often enough you wanna run
some back-end calculations or some micro
services which don't need to shouldn't
talk to the outside world they shouldn't
have a public IP but you still want to
make use of all the Google services just
cloud storage cloud logging bigquery or
any of the others
so this was very difficult in the past
because you talk of a public eye piece
to those with private access to Google
services you can enable that although
these virtual machines don't have a
private IP I don't have a public IP they
can still talk to other resources on
Google cloud platform now I want to take
that a little bit into practice practice
and demo discs so let me let me show you
a little scenario we have let's say we
have this scenario where you have three
teams one working on the web server one
working on a recommendation engine and
one working on the analytics who use a
lot of bigquery now in a traditional VPC
would put all of those in different
projects and then to talk to each other
you need to put interconnects into place
between all these projects you need to
put connections into place from each of
those projects back to your on-premise
network and you somehow need to make
sure you can talk to to our other
services
now with the features I just explained
let's take a step back what you actually
want to achieve you just want to talk
securely between the projects securely
back home and you want to talk securely
to other Google cloud services how you
do that this Google cloud but VP sees
yes you still have two different teams
and different projects they get their
separate bill split out you can set i
don't access access to do separately but
you have one shared virtual private
cloud one cross-project networking
spanning all of those projects you have
a secure connection to two cloud
bigquery over private access and you
also have a private interconnect in
place back to you on premise network
only one and the developers just have to
care about setting up their machines and
setting up their service now let's show
you how this looks like in in our
environment
so this is our Google cloud platform
dashboard and this is the networking
page so there's actually two kinds of
networks there's automatic networks
where we set up some sub networks for us
for you around the globe one one in each
of our regions and then there's the
second way which is custom networking
which you see on the bottom where we set
up where you set up the networking and
the addressing yourself now let me show
you how easy you can add as a sub
Network to this so I go into the network
I say I want to add an subnet let's say
our developers came and say they want to
test environments so I call this up
Network def test I need to say in which
region it is let's say Europe and I need
to give it an IP address range I give it
ten hundred zero zero slash 24 hit add
and I added a new sub Network now I want
to give out uh all the developers access
to my sub network over shared V PC so I
go in to share with PC and I start
actually still there let me delete it
and show you something else quickly this
is the demo so let me start from scratch
this takes about a second let's say in
the meantime the developers come back
and they say what did you do you gave us
just 200 addresses just 230 250
addresses we need more than 250 VMs for
testing give us a few more so what we
will do we can just easily say okay I
made a mistake I gave them only a slash
24 Network I go back in I I select the
different subnet range and I say I want
to extend this network not ten hundred
zero zero slash 24 but sixteen so now
they can use up to 65,000 addresses I
hope that should be enough now while
that is creating let me finally step
through the wizard and set up the cross
project networking
now first step to enable cross project
networking is you need to enable a
project as a host project so I want to
say this is my host project this is the
project where the security firewall
Network administration will happen I do
this I safe and then the next step I
need to say which subnets do I want to
share with another environment I can
either select them one by one
analytics for analytics project etc for
purpose of the demo I will just share
them all and I will continue okay and
then the last step is I need to say with
which projects do I want to share the
network so I will use my analytics
recommendation and web server project I
save this and now the cross project
networking is put into place now now we
create a secure connection that from the
other projects you can create virtual
machines automatically and easily in
this project now how does this look like
let me switch to another project let's
say I'm a developer on the analytics
team and I want to create a virtual
machine so I go to compute engine VM
instances I say I want to create a new
instance let's call it analytics one
I want to have this in Europe again and
on the networking I can select now in
which network this lies it's right now
in the default Network and here I can
select I want to actually put it in
network which was shared with me and I
want to select the analytics Network
because I'm a member of the analytics
team and that's all I need to do I
create I create the VM just normally and
then all the other teams can access it
according to the rules which were
centrally defined so this is how easily
you can create a shared network and
share it across different teams and
different projects now to recap we have
a global virtual private cloud with
private connectivity and private access
to other Google services we have we have
it shareable so you can share across
different teams and you can use a set
interconnection to your on-premise
environment and we have it expandable
you don't need to do the whole planning
ahead of time you can expand the IP
address ranges at a later stage and that
that's some of the advantages Google
virtual private cloud provides for us
and with this I want to give over to
role who will talk about BTS approach to
build your hybrid infrastructure and
thank you
Thank You Jen's pasamos ah Castellano
uno primero Agra des a ragout Bella
oportunidad que nos da de compartir NDA
minutos como so tros nuestra approxima
ciona alphys us to receive Reda's era
destrosa vosotros que no vias Taro's yo
ya todos kono sis bet a Priscilla Gary
Odyssey Rose KBT en españa y toda los
operaciones fuera Inglaterra say
scentrend are servicio a grand sem
presses fun antal meant a no esto no Co
su negocio de relative Ament a pocos
clientes con con negocios compartir dos
con ellos tratan meant a grand SSO knows
permit a entender bien que les
preocupados los clientes entender bien
cuáles son Cerritos Yo no loss principal
Jarritos
que era mismo tiene la grande cm presses
es la la digitalization ya sé que son un
concepto muy monied o male Parros cierto
que esto estará mismo en la senda de los
pissy Pele's directive o SI de los dos
committed a duration de las
organizaciones por que por que Porou
lado tenemos todos kono samos laissez
startups que están siendo y gastón
entrando el mercado con ago ce o--'s
maderos de negocio true steve-o's pero
pero tu lado tenemos negocios maduro's
que tienen que seguir funtion and ok
tienen que seguir Londo resultados pro
Kadima satan NK transform our em blow
esto un rato relavant a pork a
fundamental meant a sin era inserted
hombre a lo que no la gusta esto lo lows
a los grandes dearest Evo's Prosser todo
a low saxon east Azera grandes
organizaciones
Tiant a este inserted hombre lo primero
que tiene que hacer una gran
organization s entender que por ella
misma no vino a poder aboard our esta
trasformation por que por que hacen al
estado de inserted hombre mara query a
las em presses sol de todo que estén
preparados cuando - no sabes lo que vous
career cuando no sabes eatable RR una
startup dentro de says mezzo do nan-oh
Kanu modelo de novo C totalmente Dhiru
TiVo que puede poner embryo at
urbanization e 2 neo Co tienes que estar
and a todo preparado para estar
preparado tienes que tener muchisimas
flexible Adad tienes que tener Moochie
Sima
la edad fundamental de lo que habla
Moses de tener la capacidad de Navarre
loma rapido possible
Gaston domain or de niro posible para
give ik arm a muchas veces y que eso no
tengo limpet au lait negocio toda la
Haridas clave a la capacidad tambien
dessaline ovando la mode ellos nos a una
forma rápida como dacia y hacer esto con
un costae bajo he de sólo una una manera
Segura esto sobre el papel muy bonito me
do y esto como se si bueno pues me tengo
una manera de hacer lo lo que llamamos
nuestra vision de Graaf of clouds que
estamos de ser oh yeah no llamo loosen
and o de manera consistent a durante los
últimos cuatro años y que compart o
combo so tros nosotros hemos hecho stay
mismo a her CCO como organization a no
momento de Uno's plant a ahmo's NOS
tenemos que transform our no lo podemos
hacer solos yo status form AC own a
relavant a pensa risk a note rodda's a
note rose mercado's renault tan regula
dos ello reto son mayores yos compartir
accommo Soto's que por ejemplo de
negocio de vete en españa en el último a
oh yeah phatu ramos más de lo que no es
no co telco traditional que de lo que
sólo no servicios de integration estos
un proceso de damos a transformación
labonte en cualquier caso como venimos
lo hace una parada en nuestra capacity'
a choreo no stoma a steve-o's la red
nuestra astrati heah de de
transformation de Graaf of clouds say
tenia que construir enter no allah raise
mo de los tradicional a's kasi ahmo's
otos pony ahmo's un ce qui tow una
canción de repre baden a maple a zoo
nakhon a sunny internet uni ahmo's la
says de los clientes consult where tez y
con su sistemas que estaba en sus data
sent a's
pero que ocurre ido el paradis guma
cambia paradigm a cambia surah los
produce declawed pública de vida de lo
que no Sakon Tod o en sobre las
phantasticus capacidad a z' que tiene
google y la empresa solos usuarios mps
on a consumer a servicios que se off
Resendez una nueva pública palma Zastava
Nido muy our estrade o por los propios
usuarios los sueños que trabajan las
horas a Sione's quiere nuns are la même
asunción alle da days que usar en su
casa guess tamas más adelante
ten toes Cosimo's ad estamos lares
tenemos Kiran enter no cada vez más
Sabido oh yes un cliente boppin sumir
yes sweet a lo largo de su organization
CTN you sorry o ZM o Villa de que
también es a las casillas dead rada'han
out y tiene que a seder a lotta sin
today
Hallows valiree's de de youghal podemos
dar algunos removal adadz con las
connection de internet del mercado de
consumo
en algunas say days podemos poner Doble
connection ponemos una conexión privada
yo name Ozuna connection a internet con
car at Arista cos de empresa podemos
destroy where el tráfico que ba di Resta
mente ala cloud otra vez de sac on LC on
internet el tráfico que ba polaris
privada nostos at acento no esto
sistemas coexist a Muslera SI los meta
Mo's a Polaris privada me Tessa
preparado para esto y desde hace tiempo
yeah tenemos el servicio croco net que
nos a connection porous privada los
principal a days probe eddore's day
cloud aqui tenemos algunos de la
competencia de Nguyen y como comment odd
Oh yen's antes a dia de lo que tenemos
congruence un acuerdo de peering que
estamos con estos aqui any Spanish que
de un rena mento estupendo de ley de
menos de tres Melissa undos Y estamos
trabajando con ellos para cuando se
libera nos - brie noviembre tener a
disposition date a bozo la cancion de
tes si esto apart a darnos una conexión
poor res privada a poder careless
sousveillance
etc a betrayal beneficios por que todo
el tráfico de de SCARA desde la los
datos NTV ce o--'s cloudy day Google
Mondragon days Quentin sin cuando por
ciento que hay mucho luna de SCARA es
algo relavant a a parte de esta
connection privada que llamamos clock on
it
ok vet hecho es displayer are una serie
de nodos quedan acceso a internet la
spiffy policy or afia's donde estan
estos proverbs deck la de forma que ce
utilize ahmo's el servicio internal
debate a tenemos una calidad de servicio
de gamos mejor ah de por que de más el
transporte hasta estos puntos y ocho
punto no tenemos presencia de nodos in
turn a debate a mattress dalaras mi
Pele's son service ramos internet
oriented o
a servicios de empresas además yellow
visa bajo de poner intel
tenemos la capacidad conserv eCos ocean
ELISA bans ADO's Campanas como dynaTrace
de poder ofrecer trendy me ento astray
most Remo an evil de aplicación yeah no
habla Mo's de una res conscious clase de
servicio hablamos de que yo puedo decir
que meatus acción de sap o me
translation de analytics in real time
que es Kritika tiene una respuesta un
tiempo determine odd oh la puedo la
puedo priori sir
a lo largo de la res para que en menos
in combination dos personnel go no
estamos hablando de aquila dad you know
aspetto funa an talento de la silla da
days poder gestion are poor so we're
también me res display ramos soluciones
de se Diwan que nos permiten a balanced
air traffic automatic event a por la
conexión a reprieve odda por la
connection in the internet infusion
debris carry mentos de novo CE o que nos
permit and arma Sancho de banda yo
momento por que un Pecos station al
Osuna campaña oh so SI un proceso de CRA
que NOS demanda mess ancho de banda
speedy dante necessay de lo podemos
hacer todo de manera centralized ah de
una volution más en SI SE dabangg que lo
que llamamos hi LC p es decir
cambia Mosel Rooter traditional soon har
vard a propósito specific Oh nos a sell
routine por un Salvador okey so Cho says
a necessary or a key so Cho says esta la
Mo's super de virtualization yo podemos
empezar officer servicios directamente
desde equipo otra vez de la res gestae
na dou central mente pons / u phi worn
or mono firewall de kappa plication
Hotez pod AEC un servicio de do si
podemos poner directamente servidio
atrás de la res este tipo de servicios
indefinite Eva blah mozi no de aquila
dad Alamos de nuevo deficiency Acosta's
meter tambien como con haces tiene su
propia res de data centers tanto de
comunicaciones unification a Solis de
servicios de contact center como de
servicio CT obviamente n tan demos can
evil debt Republica competir con con
goooo converter kono so splices
complicado poor Escala pero obviamente
las organizaciones en teniendo que
necesita necesidades de aplicación esta
Dada's en internal Muslera siento no sir
at lento no CBB pay yet Assyria cetera
que que todavía son fundamentals para su
negocio Stamos la capacidad de ayudar a
los clientes a display rod cierto tipo
de cargas en esto zentorno Sol oh god oh
so no esto data centers in the desert
area sir todas esas inversiones y
valency erases Cara's con servicios yas
paso SAS loss data sent AZ Parnas como
como yo so knows yabba-dabba oooh 'no
forma on enter no e breed o lo lo que
vemos non de Porres emplo yo puedo
display Ragunan tour no de debe Saito's
un applicatio legacy in data center
debate a heap o demos conest are in
servicio de contended aur aise or
service de big query en el data center
de servicio plataforma de google y este
todo con estado otra vez de la conexión
de repre bada esta final defini lo que
le lo que es el ecosystem ax Trudeau
close care final es utilize our la res
commune Elemento in teredor que le
Dallas Hasina's como vosotros la
capacidad
della zero más que de decidir a new rent
or no como los comenta ban tase de Alta
inserted hombre resulta fundamental la
posibilidad de poder displayed our
servicios y tener una amplia bana code a
oferta in cada momento la solución came
s adata para austin na cidade de negocio
o para una de negocio concrete ax o / o
momento punto en el que esta nose
Targaryens a Chien que nos a say digamos
poder disfrute r de servicios que otros
nose ofrecen
mo suppose a guna hemp lo de de de una
noche podium oh yeah Mar ev'ry doe male
Porou lado esto como yo no soy en
escuelas mucho más de negocio home
Obispo Dover lo que voy a poner s un
vídeo que no vamos reduce sido el amor
reduce ido por que teníamos digamos que
cubrir
Elemento low morale sido para para in
Kahala nest enter no Yama na samos un
vídeo que yo no sé como hacer Londos
Pongo el video del callao del callao
hecho que esta por aqui además a Maho
CeeLo Allegra's preguntar pero que un
caso rial de una in tono de este tipo
que hemos hecho Mo's creado uniint or no
de de containers in vete para lo hará
una página web MOS extend ido assent or
no nay containers in google em hacemos
some demos como este tráfico estaba la
edad o de forma que las petit Sione's
Cavanaugh's a pagina where po dunedin
distant Ament a a los contains support
ADO's sobre en france us to a debate a
Oh los contains over todo sobre sus 2 da
de boville Eno momento da Doha samos un
proceso de attalos a she owned a subway
muy Senseo hablamos de moda fecal
imagine del des a pagina where pero hace
muchos a modification en tiempo real sin
intrusion del servicio alum or display a
continuum ito Doha Sahil displayer
Contino panorama nasty possible que nos
permit a nod and a lazada hakushi own
Camby amo Zeljko do en este caso la
imagen sin kya discontinuation de
servicio y vemos como serie fun sananda
: OD Mazzini valency on dose el tráfico
por último lo que hacemos esperar uno de
los contain adores yo emos que el
servicio se da solo desde el que que dot
even possible ejemplos nent oh no -
hasta un caso de uso de algo real cave
is a ver aqui en este caso in video no
por que no se puede hacer ahora sin oh
boy yo no sé pero a podium a muchos
otros on de poner los want a leis por
ejemplo you a la parte de Bono's met a
hurry
Stocki google cloud terminada me Deonte
un play beaucoup de ansible estamos
reckon ando los commandos de octoly
famous take a somos un gol blow s
probably case a stacked OE Hondo la
parte de de de grado yacht a music
legend rosada c ningún problema que
pasar EOC paramos uno de los puedo hacer
but I muscled okra engine and Google
never kept any most paradorians pero
como se seremos Akina a BT cloud see no
problema
Aaron knows proper training momento
graphics cable Marco Google porque
tenemos dos Eastern ahead ok parada
ma no puedo soon exemplo de un caso de
you sober obviamente podría haber otros
okay no me voy con ella dice boku mo
Isom polenta para para khan kluay
comment arroz que tenemos estamos
acostumbrado a trabajar con grandes
organizaciones same process owes de
trasformation que tenemos la vision in
yellow SOT Ivo's para para poder
accompany arroz en este viaje tenemos
los ahorros esta texaco x' Campanas como
él para capo Dyess
disfrute AR de de sus servicios y que
estamos aqui há boasted is posición en
ella stan debate a mudichu en es que
como vamos yahoo stavos de tiempo el
estará en frente la la zona de el poor
see Dennis alguna Duda con el y muchas
gracias iguanas
[Applause]
[Music]